the emergencies act is now in force but
must be debated and voted on in
parliament that debate begins tomorrow
it's required by law part of the
oversight required so that no government
can overreach its powers the scope of
those powers casts a wide net of
criminal liability david aiken looks at
what's covered by this emergency order
and how the political debate about it is
shaping up david
donna the powers detailed in the
emergencies act are broad and they could
apply right across the country
blockades or unlawful assemblies are
prohibited at all border crossings all
airports all harbors ports power
stations hospitals and so on an
exhaustive list of infrastructure assets
those who have gathered at the
parliamentary precinct are now by law
participating in an unlawful assembly
and face increased fines imprisonment or
other sanctions and anyone thinking of
joining the ottawa protest this long
weekend faces the same and at worst
you may be tying yourself to dangerous
criminal activity
it is also now illegal to bring a child
to an unlawful assembly and that's a big
deal because lots of parents have
already brought their kids to the
parliament hill occupation and the
presence of those children makes things
a lot trickier for law enforcement all
of these emergency act provisions will
automatically expire in 30 days unless
extended by the government notably it
will be up to local police forces not
politicians to decide when and where an
assembly or blockade is unlawful but
that means the emergencies act could
apply to blockades or protests in
provinces such as alberta and quebec
where there are premiers who oppose the
use of the emergencies act senators and
mps will debate and vote on these
measures later this week the black
quebecois and the conservatives will
vote against hoping to end the measures
the prime minister has not provided any
legal justification for the use of the
emergencies act a historic unfettered
power grab but the ndp are expected to
vote in favor agreeing with the liberal
rationale the measures that we've
brought forward
are targeted
temporary
and proportionate to the threat that
exists in our country now the vote in
the senate could be a bit of a wild card
in any event as politicians begin a
debate it's worth noting that the only
place right now in the entire country
where there is an illegal blockade or
protest subject to the emergencies act
is right here on parliament hill
donna
all right david aiken on parliament hill
tonight thanks